toi tu avais marqué les esprits parce
que tu es tu arrivé aux mocassins c'est
pourquoi des intervenants non le
mocassin n'était pas à mon avis le go
vous l'avez votre part je pensais que le
mocassin qu'il y avait un gland à côté
mais c'est un autre débat
d'ailleurs c'est vrai pourquoi c'était
quoi tu étais la provocation du tennis
est un sinon c'est la glace il fallait
sortir du lot il fallait c'est ça et
savoir comment faire c'est tout
exactement maxime gainey c'est la voix
douce et les mocassins la non mais c'est
dingue et qui a beaucoup marqué par
tourner à parler de ça regardez regardez
regardez les vocations bien content
après vente et le fait que que le
troupeau ne suivent pas ça me met hors
de moi
du coup les gens se sentent rassurés si
le mocassin de jungle
[Applaudissements]
time of dylan non non je sais bien que
c'est pas vrai si c'est quoi ton des
liens j'ai pas de délire justement après
nice a peut être ton délire non pas du
tout parce que les phrases là c'est
important de venir là ces trois aspects
ouais et géraldine à ou plus alors
[Applaudissements]
il a regardé rené malleville les 3
questions pour l' envie de te poser déjà
ce que tu as déjà si c'était de la
triche dans koh lanta dit la vérité
la triche conte comment on pourrait
tirer tricher donc longtemps mais alors
moi j'ai appris à dire quand tu vois des
cadreurs parions que tu cherches oui
ouais je cherche un briquet tu vois un
cadreur qui est par là bas tu suis
forcément le cadre actuel le collier
d'immunité
si le cadreur et là bas c'est que le
colis est là bas et un emploi non parce
que c'est nous qui passons devant et une
juive
ah ouais ouais ouais sur certains rien
c'est juste vérifier des quatre fois on
a quatre fois aucun indice j'aurais aimé
pourtant vraiment jamais tristan
colombet jamais et est ce que tu as déjà
eu le droit de boire un petit quelque
chose parce qu'on a il ya un conte dia
qui nous dit on peut boire un petit saut
d'avant il épreuve parfois non mais
c'est vraiment proche de 8 kg si j'avais
des canettes de coca des pizzas volonté
non mes bras mais je t'ai pas dit une
fois comme ça non c'est non je leur ai
dit sinon moi j'ai aucune gêne il le
sable alors elie à wes impression jure
son pression moi je dis toute façon le
char est bière ont l'impression comme la
bière est est ce que la production
manipulent les candidats en les poussant
au clash par exemple voilà papa ils
disent oui il faudrait que tu ailles un
peu attaquées et lointaines ou même en
vous disant tu sais ce qu a dit machine
sur thouet cessa banon fût qu'ont ils
nous parlent pas la seule la seule la
seule manière qui nous parle sans nous
posons des questions et excuse il est
question c'est comment tu trouves
clémentine tu trouves yacine servat et
casting est ce que vous êtes payé pour
koh lanta on est tous payer la même
chose après il faut bon il ya un contrat
pfi n'guessan ma gueule non mais on a
tous un contrat où on est où on signe
pour la même chose et on a tous le même
salaire sais rien je crois que ces
avancées le polo est de retour c'est un
peu plus je crois que c'était je suis
pas on tous étaient 7000 un truc comme
ça alors on va l'être dit mais il est
aussi 1,7 million star mais tout le
monde est payé à peu près 7000 10000 un
truc comme ça mais c'est tout le temps
la même chose c'est beau ouais dans ses
beaux way et après 7000 euros la semaine
non non non est ce que je vais faire koh
lanta sanaa
[Rires]
7000 euros non non non c'est l'heure pas
combien la semaine mais moi j'ai fait un
globalité avec la confidentialité avec
le relais final qui va avec
donc et donc et donc après si c'est tant
mieux si ton contrat tu nous lis ton
contrat moi j'avais fait que trois jours
et j'ai eu la chance d'être le
l'aventuré le mieux payé pour le coup
c'est pas vrai ainsi d'après 7000 euros
en trois jours non ça tout le monde a
pris çà et là le losc dans ça c'est rien
à voir et après moi je négocie mon
contrat les voilà j'ai pris à
l'équatorien draps c'est que moi il me
voulait à tout prix parce que voilà
j'avais fait ce qu'il fallait en trois
jours et j'ai négocié parce qu'il me
voulait à tout prix c'est tout c'est que
t'as négocier quoi du bonus
sale va lancer briand prix en plus les
aventures ils le savent
du coup il ya plus de cash est donc
totale j'ai pris 27 27
l'avocat ça que je vois ça fait très
chaud 27000 euros tu reste trois jours
où tu vas fukakusa les frères mais moi
mettez moi trois heures de coups je vais
là les oraux tous les gars keziah sera
hissé ou 27000 euros
c'est incroyable et bien négocié rené
malleville sur la tête de ma mère il va
en perdre sa moumoute tu vas être
prochainement dans la villa des coeurs
brisés quoi mais peut-être pas de meuf
donc t'as pas de coeur brisé et toi tu
es déçu de l'amour mais non moins
célèbre à voir si je fais passer l'amour
en dernier lieu en dernier plan donc
quoi tu vas faire là mais parce que
justement pour que l'amour je trouve une
petite place dans ma vie pour intérêts
quelqu'un baby pour trouver là on fait
que quelques jours je sais pas j'ai pas
fait la 5e peut être ou non quand même
pas si oui mais voilà je voulais tester
voilà je voulais voir succès j'ai été
vite fait tranquille sympa ou pas c'est
sympa où il ya une wilaya des coeurs
brisés
non il ya une wilaya la plage le soleil
n'a pas autour voilà on y est gratos et
moi je vois qu'on appelle les gens du
nom
nantes a fait enfin blanchiment ouais je
fais un beau blanchissement elle m'a
fait quelque chose de bien
c'est un blanchiment au blanchissement
ma langue natale c'est pas le français
décédés faute d'autre aujourd'hui mais
tu as raison mais tu as raison et nous
si on parlait français ça se saurait
paul du blanchiment et ça devrait très
bien merci et lui c'est comme ça mais
c'est un mec sérieux il cherche l'amour
to search l'amour expliqué qu'il voulait
pas chercher l'amour
ce qu'il veut c'est profiter à moi non
mais c'est quoi le projet le plan de
carrière en fait passer de koh lanta à
la villa non c'est là pour l'instant je
vais essayer de faire un maximum avec le
groupe tf1
parce que je suis rien vu par ce
programme là la preuve il laisse libre
je suis ici et bien vu par le médecin
ouais j'suis bien vu
[Applaudissements]